[Music]
YouTube what's up so so grateful that
you clicked and you're about to watch a
new youtube video but before you do - 1
2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 that is my texting
community platform doing a lot of
one-on-one engagement in there and also
access opportunity first looks in that
environment
- 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 join it now and now
to the video you've been wanting to
watch in today's climate in society I
promise you the following you want to
find a lot of negativity it's very easy
on the flip side a much more unpopular
opinion is if you want to find a lot of
happiness and opportunity you can find
it very easily
you decide you got your prospective
[Applause]
Carrie why don't we start off by why
don't you tell them a little bit about
what vaynermedia is you know obviously
saw in the video you know I try to make
it as simple as possible all all we
really are is a agency you know I think
what makes us different is because I
didn't come from the agency landscape
and more importantly because I built
vaynermedia with the intent to be a
platform for buying businesses and
brands during the next economic downturn
it's been built very differently the
first thing that was different was that
we have media and creative under one
house not part of a holding company
where it's separate companies but from
day one it was built where both media
and creatives sit together and the
context and the end consumer is truly
not through reporting not through data
but truly at the forefront and we think
about math and art as friction to create
diamonds not one is more valuable than
the other and then really the only other
big variable differences it's you know a
dictatorship you know and what I mean by
that is I don't have a board I don't
have a Holding Co everything wrong at
Boehner is 100% my fault and when is
when something's run by an
entrepreneurial operator a lot of good
can happen in growth and a lot of
growing pains and silly young things
happen and I definitely think we're
dramatically more contemporary than
every alternative at the global scale we
have Singapore London you know we have a
thousand people you know it's not a
small company I spend a lot of time
actually strategically making it about
me
look over here look at this crazy guy so
that I can operate something that I
think is quite disruptive over here and
I'm proud of that
but it's a I think it's a very different
shop because it comes from a very
different agenda you know we're not held
accountable to every 90 day finance
goals and I think that has been a
massive advantage no and no getting on a
call with analysts and appeasing some
short-term narrative that's an inside
vig game
I remember a meeting that we had at one
point where you came to us and said you
know you would bring new channels to us
for example and when a Pinterest and you
talk to us about Pinterest and one time
you came and said you guys gotta figure
out soundcheck you've got to be on
snapchat it's the future and at that
point it was just something that might
that my kids did and I couldn't figure
it out what what's what's next and
what's new in it's interesting Trish
even in that it's very rare very rare
though I'm a human I'm sure I slip up
but I would argue if we had film of me
bringing up snap in time that it was
more likely that I didn't refer to it as
the future and I never predict I'm just
completely obsessed with right now what
I know right the second as we sit here
and everybody watching around the world
that LinkedIn and tick tock are the two
platforms that give you organic reach if
you do not pay media if you're a nobody
and you post on either one of those two
platforms something great can happen
that cannot happen outside of a miracle
point zero zero zero zero one percent
chance on Facebook Twitter Instagram and
YouTube those things always fascinate me
because I love underpriced real estate
you know if I came to somebody
twenty-five years ago and said there's
an island called Turks and Caicos and I
genuinely believe more people will go to
it over the next twenty five years and
we bought our property everybody would
be happy so I spent all my time on two
core things one under priced organic
reach which often is more at a small
entrepreneurial SMB level at the
corporate level they're important
because I want companies to get the reps
of understanding the nuances that are
making this platform pop and
understanding LinkedIn today is very
different than all of us understanding
it four years ago it's a completely
different beast LinkedIn today acts much
more like Facebook did six years ago
than it does with the LinkedIn that we
all grew up using which was a tool not a
content platform the things I'm learning
on tik-tok now will matter because those
are getting instilled into 12 and 19
year old
right now and those will become nuances
that quite matter in communication in
three five seven nine years obviously
Chase is less likely to be obsessed with
understanding tick-tock
in comparison to bands or in comparison
to Mattel right so you think about all
those things but I don't know what's
next what I do know is that I'm
incredibly good at understanding as a
human subjectively intuitively of what
seems to be current and then I put a ton
of disciplined and work ethic and
dollars and effort into proving those
hypothesis to be true or false
okay I think the platforms are making a
ridiculously personal I think it's smart
I think that platforms revenue from
political ads is not significant enough
in return for what the headlining and
positioning means to it and all the
vulnerabilities of had we are in a fully
on tilt headline reading society the
amount of opinions in this room from the
two of us to everybody in this room to
everybody who's watching where we have
deep convictions and thoughts predicated
on one or two headlines is laughable
so a I think was a smart move by Jack I
think it helps Twitter but I think that
they the platforms have done an
incredibly bad job in distinguishing
what a platform is people are way on
tilt on believing that they're
manipulating something
I mean Marc's opportunity when AOC asks
him like will you police this truth is
easily rebuttal dwith can we have CNN
and Fox do that too like we are we're at
a very funny place where we ask modern
technologies to do things that we don't
hold traditional technologies
accountable for so great but I think in
the macro they're doing a poor job I
would I'm very curious what the very
differences between not fact-checking an
ad in a Facebook feed versus not
checking a fact coming out of a news
anchors mouth on a news platform please
please I love pushing back a bit I don't
view technology any different than I
look at humans this is one big game of
communication do we have data that shows
what Carson Tucker or Don Lemon mean
when they say something that's my push
back my push back is when are we gonna
hold ourselves accountable for the
information you know like you know
whether a bot is run to run more ads or
more a potential awareness against a
headline or a newscaster uses an
adjective in a way that pushes that
information I genuinely do not see the
variable difference to the end consumer
I would argue people are hearing what
they want to hear like I don't know I
see plenty of things coming on Facebook
and CNN and Fox and Twitter that I'm a
big enough boy to decipher what I want
to believe or tend to believe or I'm
curious about this notion that we're so
helpless that the second that we see
something we believe it to be true I
think it's the reverse I think we're
justifying what we want to be true
through the propaganda
educated consumer and be discerning by
putting in the work how many people here
are gonna be keyboard warriors about
politics and not even registered a boat
how should we do it
the same way we do everything remember
when you blindly believed everything out
of your parents mouth you grew up it's
time we do that with media when I wrote
it in 2008 and the book came out no 9
the thought of building a viable
business or lifestyle on the back of
YouTube or Twitter was a laughable event
if you go to Amazon right now and look
at the first 500 reviews of crush it
that were published in 2009 basically
it's a mix of this guy is completely a
snake oil salesman to social media we'll
be gone next year there was not a belief
that the nuf scale could happen on these
platforms to create something meaningful
so what's evolved is the acceptance from
the masses that there is power behind
these platform 2009 where people didn't
believe me that these platforms were
powerful enough for you to be able to
make $80,000 a year to us now feeling
like we have to break up these companies
because they're so powerful in dictating
our minds so that's change the
perception of the power of social
networks which oh by the way are just
the current state of where our attention
is on the Internet itself whether this
goes to a R or VR or voice all this is
is where are we paying attention to you
know so that's that's the biggest change
the things that are the same are my
belief that there's a lot of people here
in this room watching who have a certain
perspective on how they're gonna live
their life
what is gonna bring the most happiness
to them and I want to continue to beat a
drum of do not underestimate the power
of this platform do not underestimate
what it feels like to be desperately
happy making a hundred three thousand
dollars a year doing something you love
versus being unhappy making a hundred
ninety seven thousand dollars a year
spending it on things to disguise your
unhappiness
[Music]
[Music]
um you know it's funny it's really hard
to ask a giraffe to be a penguin or vice
versa and so one thing that's become
much more obvious to me as I've gotten
older it's like wow
DNA is powerful like I'm so comfortable
with no and losing and fear but I'm so
empathetic to people that aren't I and
this will surprise a lot of you that
maybe follow me I'm unbelievably
comfortable with aggressiveness and
candor and binary talk on stage but one
on one I've really struggled over the
last 25 years as an executive with
radical candor and shooting it straight
because I'm so optimistic and I'm always
trying to fix it and so that's taken me
a lot of work and through that work I'm
like okay you know there's the things
that come natural and the things that
aren't if you grew up in a framework
with parents or customs that really
desperately overvalued outside
affirmation the opinions of your parents
as parents or siblings because you come
from let's call it what it is an
immigrant background where there's a
huge commonality there school you were
so deeply bought into school that the
short term affirmation of every
any days with grades and report cards
made you comfortable it's very hard to
then go into hey hey this is what you
should learn from entrepreneur land like
don't worry about it it's all gonna be
fine that's very hard you've fully built
yourself as an animal to completely
value outside judgment that is not based
on the market but based on another human
being that's what I'd like people to
learn which is like hey like what are we
doing here you've won the 400 trillion
to one lottery of being a human being do
you really want to live with regret like
do you not understand that the Internet
is the greatest optionality in the
history of mankind that our grandparents
and everybody behind them had nowhere
close to the options you sit with today
and really like what are you valuing
that's making you conform into doing
something that doesn't make you happy
your current overhead so sell your home
and rent that sounds crazy you know when
I started talking about like hey in the
pursuit of happiness would you consider
selling your home and renting I mean I
got destroyed in the comments sections
and it allowed to play like like that
I'm some horrible person I'm like how is
living your life to pay the bills that
you've created for yourself that's all
humans all that humans do or create
their own jails and then live within it
that's all we do so so knowing that
that's very hard in a human way the
situation you have with your parents all
that stuff the professional one feels
like I have a prayer of communicating
that and letting people and here's my
point if you want to be a professional
skier or if you want to start a blog or
podcast around cooking my big thing is
if you jump and start swimming you know
this is riding a bike kissing a boy or
girl or you know swimming this is it
seems super scary until you do it and
then you just laugh about why I felt so
scary like if you go do that thing and
live more humble live with judgment you
could always get a job again like I
don't know like I just my great fear is
regret because it is the obvious thing I
see in people that are 80 to 100 years
old that seems super scary
nobody was thrilled that they played it
safe it just you don't see it and I
think people should spend more time with
8200 year olds that aren't their
grandparents I mean it I mean it I think
people need context on life a little bit
I think people have a horrible
relationship with time do you don't need
people in this room are scared shitless
of 30 like it's some thing it means
nothing but our society's decided to
tell you that you have to fit figured
out to marry even children and what are
you talking about 98% of the 59 year
olds I know don't have it figured out
the hell are we supposed to have it all
figured out at 30 25 like people are
making terrible decisions getting
married because they think they're
supposed to by this age you know like
buying homes because they think they're
supposed the rules of modern society
have led to everybody wants to blame
technology you know and drug companies
for you know all our problems we need to
blame our norms our expectations are
ridiculous North Stars that have make no
sense we're living when I look at this
young of a crowd they're living to a
hundred and ten there's an enormous
amount of people in here that are gonna
live to 110 and are freaking out that
they don't have it figured out by 30
you're not even a [ __ ] quarter of the
way there yet what are we talking about
so in you know that's very heady stuff
in its practical layer of a business and
life and jobs and career I think
everybody owes it to themselves to start
something on the side around something
that they're really desperately in you
the reason a lot of entrepreneurs are
alquiler are workaholics
there's a whole there's a whole
different reason they're alcoholics
honestly I'll just go to that for a
minute
entrepreneurship is super lonely I hate
that entrepreneurship is cool now
because people that are not
entrepreneurs are jumping in and it is a
dangerous lonely game if you're not a
purebred you will get eaten up if you
don't love losing and love the struggle
and love the push back you will use
you'll be unhappy but the reason that a
lot of entrepreneurs are workaholics is
because they love it they got lucky they
like literally love like I remember not
loving it I mean being in school looking
at the clock from first period on those
things one day in high school feels
longer than the last decade of my life
I mean that and I know there's an
enormous amount of people here at this
rate exact moment that are already
counting down Friday and that's not good
and that's not good for chase and that's
not good for them and so we need a
better debate and it starts with what we
spend our money on a lot of people like
Gary but how am I supposed to live in
New York City I'm like don't like don't
like like we have to get more binary
around happiness I really believe that
hey guys sorry to interrupt your video
I'm just giving you this call for my
number to let you know that you have to
join my text community to one two nine
thirty one five seven three one two hit
me up with a text
so therefore I have to go on the
communications path and then I have to
be a more senior communicator we have
place like JP Morgan Chase you can like
mary said you can move to London you can
move to Dubai and take the risk of
people are terrified rich people people
are in the business of no people are in
the business of saying no before they
asked people prefer to blame the Machine
I'm aware I have it at Bainer I'm a full
hardcore open-door policy but some
people would rather go to the bathroom
and vent that actually talked to me when
I've proven over the last half decade
how unbelievably safe it is to talk to
me practice I've been thinking a lot
about this lately I think you have to
challenge yourself
listen careers are a big personal reason
I talk so much about work is it's a
scary percentage of our entire life the
amount of time you spend working and
comparison that everything else you do
is when you add sleeping into the
equation it gets really intense so I
really push people here and how do you
do it if it's too hard to do here
because you were a student and you're in
a machine and now you this and it like
you have to try to do things outside of
like I actually think somebody here off
of this talk who then goes and tries
skiing I don't know why I'm stuck in
that today for the first time and never
was a skier or cooking or going to you
know an opera doing something completely
uncomfortable may start the process of
doing something uncomfortable here I
think it's practice I think you need it
by the way let me give you I like to go
literal once a while some I'm hoping one
person does this go volunteer at a
nursing home for one day in your life a
I think you'll get a lot of value of
what I talked about earlier cuz
perspective is the game and you can get
it real quick if you go into that jungle
and be that's you doing something
uncomfortable I think people have to
break patterns I think you do something
different or build courage to do
something different by getting used to
it the great
action of my life was I was an immigrant
who got picked on for not being able to
speak English I was a terrible student I
was not good at sports I basically lived
the first 18 years of my life telling me
that I was a losing platter so I got
real cozy with losing I loved losing
it's why I associate so much more with
people that don't come from privilege
you know whether they look that part and
I look I view privilege
first and foremost we don't have the
date you know we can see a white male
looks privileged we can see somebody
who's well-off financially as privileged
the real privilege game in our society
is what's going on in everybody's dome
mental privilege is number one right
when uh that's um I I wish P this is why
I'm talking so much about parenting we
are living through the worst execution
of parenting in our society because
we're living through such enormous
success abundance and prosperity in
America for the last 60 70 years and so
now parents are getting into things you
know parents during the Great Depression
struggled with going to school and
yelling at the parent at the teacher for
not doing this that or the other thing
so we're living in eighth place trophies
fake environments entitlement there are
kids in this room right now who take
money from their parents and are over at
the age of 22 I believe that that is the
number one poison in our society I
believe it creates enormous fake
environments it subconsciously tells
children that they're not capable and
they need their parents help and fake
environments are bad and it leads to bad
behavior
we don't do you know that our society
doesn't talk about saving money at all
we don't talk about saving money at all
we don't talk about borrowing money from
our parents and paying them back that's
what two generations ago used to do now
we just we're so [ __ ] entitled we
just expect this is what you know
everybody always asks me like hey how do
I manage you know these Millennials I'm
like with empathy they were parented in
an environment where if you came in
ninth they clapped for you
I don't think that I listen I think this
isn't a super important subject matter
I'm not saying do somebody and make them
feel like I believe in I'm a product of
self-esteem my mom did the greatest she
also created accountability and we
really need to debate that listen I'm a
hardcore DNF student so I'm not
interested in hypocrisy my daughter
who's ten looks like she's a big-time
student I think she studied more
yesterday than I did in my entire career
and I and that's awesome I have no
interest in frowning on that I think
that's great and as long as that makes
her happy and we have proper
conversations around that I don't think
my son's gonna go exactly that route but
for me it's not about demonizing the
system it's about it's about having a
360 conversation I have no interest in
my children being entrepreneurs if they
happen to have that DNA and that makes
them as the only thing I want my kids to
do is be as happy as I am in what they
do you know if they look at my and look
now there's a new variable things with
me continue to grow I'm very empathetic
that they may look out and be like I
don't want any part of that and I'm
gonna go to Peru and give away all his
money right and I'm good with that I
really am I'm really good with that
like like I really really just want them
to find their thing and if their thing
is something that I you know maybe I'm
not as passionate about which is be more
within the system create less risk my
kids could say you know what I hate
entrepreneurship it made dad travel a
lot I hate it that makes sense to me and
so
my biggest patent my communication with
my children is more about them truly
looking for their happiness and
understanding the world will evolve
quite a bit by the time they hit the
real world and and leaning into the
happiness but practically you want to go
paint with tomatoes and Peru that's
amazing just FYI I'm not giving you one
dollar and and if and that's amazing
like like like to me if they're gonna
like live with like four friends in a
commune that's tremendous that's awesome
like to me it's just about merit and
happiness practical optimism so my
number number one thing that I think may
be very unique and couldn't be more
passionate and delivering to this
audience as the following I really
highly recommend that you die on your
own sword let me explain what I mean by
that every day a lot of you are in
meetings where things are being talked
about that you may have some insights
opinions and actual knowledge about and
you are not communicating an opposing
view because you know that it won't be
accepted by the managers above you and
you think it's a vulnerability by
communicating it and I think it's the
reverse I think there's an incredibly
soft and respectful way for you to
create a data point to the conversation
and that I believe this is what I see a
lot happening where people don't say
anything because they're appeasing how
to move up manager to manager manager
the world actually changes and then the
company resets and the executive by not
saying something gets viewed upon as
that was their point of view and they
get hurt by pandering to the Machine
verses by being historically correct in
the room when all those executives
either grow
within the organization or dispersed to
other organizations they become an
interesting prospect to bring along
because they were historically correct
I'm giving advice that I take as an
entrepreneur my businesses are always
much slower and smaller up front because
I'm often talking about and executing on
something that hasn't been accepted in
the macro yet and all the upside is on
the back end
I think people in here are sitting on
their words and they shouldn't and
everybody knows it this entire room is
in meetings every day when we talk about
things that they don't agree with and
they don't say a single word I don't
think you should say I'm the way I do I
say them aggressively in my jersey style
because I have nobody who can fire me no
I mean that the client can fire me and
then not that would be my fault but I
understand why executives can't do what
I do but there's but if I was a senior
executive or my first day intern knowing
my communication sound DNA I would just
do it very politely and soft but I would
say look I don't think banner ads you
know even though the data shows that
it's doing well I think we're only
looking at short-term conversions and
not factoring in LTV and it has
declining CAC and what's the value of
that customer and you know I would share
my thoughts the key that I noticed is
but you have to know what you're talking
about
where a lot of people get caught is they
think they know what they're talking
about and then they say something and
they're wrong one of the things that's
super interesting to me is I talked
about a very narrow thing I stay very
narrow I'm just not interested in being
wrong so I actually stay quiet for all
the talking I do I'm quiet around 99.9%
of things so I don't get involved in a
lot of other subject matters I could
talk about marketing I could talk about
the Jets offensive line woes you know I
could talk about wine but I keep it
narrow cuz I don't know about health
care
that's for sure every one of us does but
that's not the kind of thing that I
would stake in the ground for you know
career advancement you know my favorite
soap my favorite so many o Blanc's tend
to be from the Sancerre region in France
because I tend to like Stoney flinty
flavors more than the grass that you get
from New Zealand and more than I mean I
think California so Mel Blanc sucks so
so Sancerre Lucien crochet is a great
producer so I would say that and then on
cab
I think cab is the most overpriced wine
in the world it became very popular
I think Napa Valley cabs are wildly
overpriced so for Cabernet maybe a maybe
a Bordeaux based cab from the Medoc
because I tend to like a little more
vegetal and nuanced flavors so and by
the way it's similar to media it's not
that I hate television commercials I
just think there's better alternatives
I think there's better o if you love
Cabernet and I'm sure 90% of people that
like red wine like it to some degree to
love it I just know that there's
alternatives in Portugal alternatives in
Argentina that can appease your big
fruit silky creamy oaky flavors for a
third of the price it's never about
anything other than arbitrage for me so
it's not that Napa cabs suck or Cabernet
sucks it's that you're paying for the
brand AB DAPA cab and you're not
educated to know that you can get that
fulfillment from the prio rat in Spain
by the way uh no just to make a segue
into some of the stuff I talk about that
is absolutely my thesis in marketing I
don't hate direct mail you can show me
direct mail that works I just don't know
if you've perfectly executed one mile
radius Facebook Ads with contextual
creative to the person that's seeing it
that's all that when I had the awakening
at 34 of like wait a minute
I'm not a great retailer I'm a great
communicator I built this business from
three to sixty million dollars with no
money because I was right about
e-commerce I was right about email I was
right about Google AdWords I was right
about YouTube I was right about Twitter
all five things I just told you
you guys are youngsters when I started
winelibrary.com in 1996 people told me
the internet was a fad the whole thing
forget about snapchat or vine or
tick-tock the whole thing you know
people that sold the yellow pages in a
Chamber of Commerce event made fun of me
as like you know like this kids like
he's gonna be wrong like he doesn't know
he's a child and I was like the
consumers always right I don't even feel
like I'm a human being all I think I am
is a pass-through to what humans are
actually doing I'm not right about
tick-tock humans are doing it there's a
hundreds of millions of people using it
this is not prediction time this
happened I love people like what's next
you're Nostradamus you predict I'm like
I'm a post game newscaster I'm not
Nostradamus um I'm like Howard Cosell
this happened podcasting happened yeah
LinkedIn happened like I've never
predicted a thing in my life
I'm just not scared to execute on what's
actually happening because I'm not in
the business of making reports or
politics my North Star
let's go and there's one over there for
next how are you my question pertains to
you know I want her to be safe I want to
try to to some degree hopefully ensure
she doesn't really get off track in
provider that's cool that's things like
that but I know they didn't mentioned my
philosophy and just want to get your
advice on from a parent Yeah right like
why do you kind of say you know yeah I
got it
look first of all my interest in giving
any specific person parenting advice is
zero point zero I think I think
everybody needs to parent the way they
decide to pair it I like communicating
the alternatives to what I think is
being accepted especially no different
than tick tock happened i I
Gary Vaynerchuk get over a thousand DMS
a week on Instagram from kids that are
deeply resentful of their parents for
over manipulating their lives I'm
talking about I hate my parents because
they pay for my equinoxes in uber I
reply and say then stop taking the money
dick but I also know what's going on at
a higher level which is parents are
using their children's as products to
impress their contemporaries the reason
parents pay is not necessarily because
they want to help the kid it's they want
their friend their sister their their
parents or others to think little Johnny
and Sally are successful so you need to
do you but let me say this I don't
understand why people can't remember
them being kids like I love parents
they're like I restrict my kids time on
their phone I'm like they've seen porn
you know like like this notion that like
we can control life is laughable and
more importantly we're giving indicators
into kids that we don't trust
which creates self-doubt which really
leads to a lot of unhappiness so look
you get to pick your North Star
my North Star is self-esteem and
accountability and Happiness not Harvard
not entrepreneurship not winning you
know that I want them to be happy
big time I want them to be accountable
if you know I'll never forget I struck
out four I was a really good baseball
player in third and fourth grade before
talent kicked in and this one kid John
Longo was a real pitcher big fat Italian
kid if you're watching John and because
he was so big he could throw gas and he
just overpowered me and I went over four
and struck out four times which was
unheard of because I was really up like
my apex then and I just remember my mom
coming in and I came in and started
looking for excuses like I should have
batted fourth today
it was sunny she was like you struck out
four times meanwhile this was the woman
who when I opened the door for an
elderly woman had McDonald's once
treated it as a Nobel Prize winning
award behavior so she created enormous
self-esteem but not delusion right this
whole listen if you're five foot four
and your parents are telling you yes you
can go to the NBA
Abraham that's fine that's fine but it
needs to be added with and you will be
one of the only three people in the
history of the sport and oh by the way
Mugsy Bogues and spud Webb could do all
these other things that you are showing
that you cannot we are we are like this
you can be anything delusion is what's
leading to a lot of resentment and
pushback and so you I would just tell
you that delusion and more importantly
what you put on a North Star today will
change
I mean look college is under siege
there's gonna be seven or eight colleges
with enough brand equity in 15 years to
maintain their spot but the rest of them
are in real trouble I'm 43 and I was
making $5,000 a weekend selling baseball
cards is a 12 13 14 year old and was
considered a loser today I'm in the Wall
Street Journal because entrepreneurship
is cool that
then if you didn't go to a great college
you had no chance of happiness or
success by the time your kid in 14 years
enters the time to go into school or an
18 years comes out of it I have a funny
feeling the rules will be different so
keep that in mind
and then I apologize and you decide you
decide what that is not me not the game
not your parents you you know which is
what gets me into process why do I want
people to do what they love because like
if you're chasing something for
affirmation you're in trouble I don't
want the trophies I don't want the
accolades I want the game
[Music]
the truth the truth the truth the truth
is undefeated that's it and people are
scared of the truth that's the only
advantage you have there's so much
content being produced today the only
way you actually can break through is
your unique truth it's just true there's
just a volume of creative and
consumption that we've never seen before
so that to build you've gotta lean into
your uniqueness my truth of baseball
cards and flea marketing and rupee ER
and the Jets and wine those are the
unique things that make me feel a little
bit different than others it's also a
lot easier to produce content when you
don't have to think my friends it's a
lot easier to produce content when you
don't have to think that's right and the
reason I brought up document and dough
creators I'm not scared of my truth my
strengths my weaknesses it's not fun
when you're actively the CEO of a
thousand person company to actively
always constantly talk about struggling
with radical candor knowing your
employee sees that and then if sitting
in front of you and you're dancing
around like you know like they you know
like you know the last scene of M&M
eight-mile last scene most important
scene in mute in movie history I believe
it I believe it in that battle rap by
him exposing himself he left nothing for
the opposing party the most unhappiness
you will ever have is the secrets you're
hiding because you don't want anybody to
have that leverage once you let it go
you become fundamentally unstoppable
you're welcome
let's go to that lady first we'll go to
this gentleman next hi thank you yes
thank you so it's really serendipity I
started a fund in in at the same time
that my friend Ben Leventhal was just
leaving
his current gig we had dinner one night
and he's like I've good news eater just
got sold to box like I'm like I'm good
news I'm starting a fund like maybe we
should do something together and
literally during that dinner we were
like you know maybe what uber did for
taxis we can do for the supply and
demand of restaurant seats and that was
our opening thesis which was why don't
restaurant seats sell like Airlines more
than just like the same price
there was no supply and demand metric
totally that's not what resi became but
we learned after 24 months was open
tables not that good so let's just go
right at that that's what we did and
that's what eventually led to its great
success and the enormous eggs that we
had recently and so serendipity I'm a
counter-puncher a much more floyd
mayweather than mike tyson I don't like
wake up and like I'm gonna go kill that
I'm more living living listening
listening listening I'm like oh sports
agency to as much passion as I have to
buy the Jets I never viewed it as I'm
gonna start a Jerry Maguire like
business and then buy the Jets but then
when I started looking and hearing I'm
like how this industry could be
disrupted so I spent a lot of time
listening I always say that to people
that follow me most hardcore I'm like
every second you don't see me I'm
listening
that's why I love QA it's why I read my
DMS it's why I started my text platform
because people feel even more
comfortable
telling me I want the truth right that's
where the real stuff is I would have
never gone into parenting if I mean you
know I came from my parents giving me
nothing so I'm sure for a lot of even
when I said people complaining about
their parents paying you should have
seen everybody's face here like the fact
I wish my parents paid for me
right I would have never known that I
would have never known what kind of
sadness people that were getting
subsidized would actually feel you know
we don't have empathy for other people's
problems
we think our problem is the problem and
so a lot of listening that and that's
what my next businesses will be will be
because I've listened did a little
homework see the blood in the water
shark it up
of course by doing that you listen to
the way you just said it the fact that
you know that it's content which it is
communication is how everything happens
documenting it which you understand it's
kind of like you saying how do I get
healthier you know I know I have to eat
better and workout every day but how do
I really do it Gary I'm like my eating
better and working out every day you're
talking about a lack of patience no
nonprofit that has no awareness and
didn't exist should be getting an
overflow of donations that's not how it
works you need to put out content you
need to devalue the production value and
up value the output and that's it now
the tactics of do you run ads against
high net worth individuals on the Upper
West Side yes you know like you fish
where the fish are but it's just making
content and making sure it's seen
whether you have no money and have to go
organic LinkedIn and tick tock or
whether you do have money and then all
of a sudden Facebook pre-roll YouTube
Instagram story swipe up ads become your
framework that's the game rinse and
repeat you're welcome
it's got questions there's two up
gentlemen up here there's a young lady
right there let's go right there look
you'll go to her next awesome
it's you bro yeah Congrats
how are you thank you thank you yep yes
yes yes yes yeah yep yes to make them
way less long but to answer your
question both I think it's important to
have a Swiss Army knife to your point
sometimes I'm going into the meeting
because I need more context and then
I'll go creative and sometimes I'm
trying to deliver something and I'll go
more tactical I think they both work I
just think they all run way too long
there's not a single meeting that
anybody in this room has been on that
wasn't too long I fully believe that
you're welcome how are you
no but I do think the vlog has a little
bit of that obviously you probably know
this I'm quite private
you know I share nothing about my family
or personal life so I don't like I do
bees right first of all I would have
never I would never let a network have
that much control or economic upside
knowing the world that I live in but
even then I have too much empathy for
them because they would want all the
other stuff and that's just a line I'm
not willing to cross so no but but I
definitely think the blog and what we do
with daily be gets into the nuances of
it and I enjoy the ability to control
the narrative and and not do hellacious
things for Nielsen ratings and you know
I'm just not willing listen I am never
ever going to be part of a machine that
I don't control because
doesn't sound interesting to me and
that's why I would never do that to over
here I have no preference the just as
many as I'm fundamentally the byproduct
of not sticking to one thing like I'm in
the business of trying to juggle 50
balls and knowing 13 of them will fall
and being thrilled about that cuz I'm 37
balls in the air because I've had one
ball in there I'd want to call it quits
and I think you should do what you want
to do you know what I mean you know
Noah banks such a good [ __ ] name
I will yeah but bro and this is for
everybody this will always happen there
are fundamentally it's very historically
true there's the black and white way and
the great way and things have been flow
they have their moments I don't even
know what book you're talking about
focus on one thing but it has its moment
and then next week some young lady's
gonna put out a book called do sixty
four things and it will have its moment
this is a self-awareness game I'm not
right I'm just comfortable doing me I'm
just hopeful you can do that too
there is no right you want to be type a
cross every T make seven hundred lists a
day amazing just make sure that that
you're doing it because that's how you
like it right that's it there is only
the way that you will always win when
you lean into your natural upside people
are open our society is built to sell
you on closing the gap on your
weaknesses all the upside is tripling
down on your strengths how are you James
I love it yes geez um I think my biggest
failure was working every minute of my
20s and when I say every minute I mean
all of them
like no weekends no friends I think I
over I was just too hungry you know like
that's why I've always liked Kobe you
know where it's like a like he gets a
little like it almost feels like it's a
little evil and dangerous I'm like I get
that like it was I went too far balance
matters and I think I resent and regret
and and I really don't which is why I
even took a pause but I think the
biggest thing I learned about that is
you know it wouldn't killed me to you
know go out a couple Friday thanks so I
think I'm more balanced at at 43 then I
was at 23 but bro I'm gonna tell you
something I'm really trying to manifest
an answer for you it's unbelievable how
much practice I have on the inability to
dwell
you know I passed on uber twice on the
angel round from one of the people that
I was best friends with while investing
in a bunch of other things and that
$50,000 investment would have been would
be worth 900 million dollars that was a
mistake
you know there's there's so many
mistakes I mean like I make a mistake
every day of my life like a lot of them
like especially now where I'm crippled
by opportunity like you know every every
day I'm fundamentally sure of the
following sentence every day I'm making
pretty big mistakes because I'm saying
no to something that could have led to
the big thing of happiness or success
I'm just not crippled by that I just
don't understand why people spend time
on that do you meet people that are in
college debt spend 80% of their down
time being resentful that they took on
debt for something they've come to
realize didn't bring them as much value
in return the problem is it's over like
I'd much rather if they took all that
time garage saling and going to teach
max and flipping they could start
chipping away at the debt t.j.maxx is
loaded with arbitrage it is you'd go to
t.j.maxx spend a thousand dollars and
make four thousand on eBay and Amazon
every day the week but instead of making
that three thousand dollars of putting
in work instead of watching Netflix or
going to do something else people would
rather sit and complain why they pick
people would rather sit in a bar on a
Friday afternoon buy an $18 cocktail and
complain that they're in college debt
then do what I just said nothing I just
lived I actually think that's the answer
I believe that a lot of people
overcorrect with tutoring make I believe
that humans especially today are making
mountains out of molehills like I'm sure
my team that's here will tell you the
company-wide emails that I send one of
the things I run in slack have no
grammar structure whatsoever I don't
even think grammar structures a word
like like like nothing bro you know why
I don't give a [ __ ] what they think of
how I'm talking there there are people
right now that didn't like that I cursed
four times during this talk and decided
not to hear everything I just talked
about I can't control that
I can't and and more importantly I bring
this up now in the meta because if
you're one of those people on simulcast
or in this room if that's what you're
deciding to focus on there's a real
problem there's a real problem in life
you find what you're looking for in
today's climate in society I promise you
the following you want to find a lot of
negativity it's very easy on the flip
side a much more unpopular opinion is if
you want to find a lot of happiness and
opportunity you can find it very easily
you decide
[Applause]